[Music]
all right so in a world where we woke up
saw the Top Gun maverick trailer and saw
the it trailer knows like or I'll do a
video on it trailer doesn't he's doing
on Top Gun now Rick I like what I saw
but people care I saw a few people the
conversation were like you're really not
good Top Gun Matt don't wash the trailer
again I was like alright yeah yeah I
want to talk about this I know me making
the small leap between I'm not gonna do
a video on the trailer
that's a sequel to that movie I like to
all right maybe I'll talk about the
trailer to the sequel to Top Gun it's
not the same leap I would have to take
to do a video on the cat's trailer I
don't give a [ __ ] that they made cats to
make that leap like none of the
Knievel's could make the leap I'm
keeping these on the entire time by the
way the things I can Top Gun maverick
are honestly is first of all you get the
tone you get the note set bail it's like
a slower version of it really brings out
the fields but I do like that tone I
mean I thought we may came out with a
trailer be like that that's at that
diner on highway to the dangerzone
maverick could be like blowing [ __ ] up
that's gonna be like 80s in 2019 come on
in another that never happens
everything's that 80s throwback these
days but not a Top Gun throwback because
the Top Gun throwback is all the beat
sports body oil you could possibly
muster but you got ed Harris kind of
grilling him like 30 plus years of
service the only pilot to shoot down
three enemy craft in the past 40 years
well you haven't been promoted what the
hell it's one of life's mysteries sure
but it's not a mystery
look there's no mystery there simply put
Mavericks a Star Trek fan that's what I
learn from this maverick listened to
James Tiberius Kirk SCID vice
don't let them promote you don't let
them transfer you don't let them do
anything the car didn't listen to it
apparently he got promoted my dad used
but maverick listened Top Gun is highway
to the dangerzone now that Mavericks
been on that highway for about 30 years
he is now in the danger zone the danger
of being obsolete the end is inevitable
maverick you kind of set it for
extinction sounds like fun
and I like that I like the fact that
this trailer makes it look like Top Gun
Mavericks gonna have maverick dealing
with his mortality if not just physical
mortality you know like a death wish
doing the death-defying stunts I'm
talking about conceptual mortality like
the mortality of your place in the world
likes flying he's a fighter pilot but
apparently that's becoming obsolete so
he has to deal with that he also doesn't
want to get promoted because he wants to
keep flying I like that that's the
eternal struggle we all will eventually
deal with like I always think about that
for myself and the Jets the flying
scenes they look pretty sweet now we're
breaking sonic booms baby this is
probably gonna be one of those movies
where at Mavericks becoming obsolete and
then something happens where they find
out hey we still need those Mavericks
they still lay time gosh darn it and all
is gonna be great because the world will
conform to what maverick wants to be his
place in the world it'll actually give
it props if that doesn't happen like
Mavericks forced to just retire because
that's more or less how the world works
you know like more often than not the
world doesn't really conform to the
needs or wants of the individuals people
are forced to make the tough calls of
tough decision maybe so sorry but not
today I just hope he's still maverick
and it trailer makes it look like yeah
he is he's just older maverick older
maverick flying in the face of the abyss
all right so the Top Gun maverick
trailer the trailer to the sequel the
Top Gun not that what happened have you
seen the trailer what did you think
about it whatever you thought comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
[Music]